Gary lineker just arriving at the King
Power Stadium for that Premier League
match this afternoon between Leicester
city and Chelsea so if we talk about the
Fallout at the BBC surrounding Gary
lineker as we've discussed the tweet and
the politics around it is it fair for I
mean as someone who who sits in the
House of Lords but who's also been a
journalist before is it fair for people
who have high profiles like Gary lineker
to use their position to air opinions
and how does that marry with being a
part of the BBC
in Europe
I think it's perfectly okay for the bbbc
to have guidelines that it won't sits
senior people and indeed all its people
perhaps
to follow but it's important that if
there are guidelines they're applied
fairly and I can't understand why Gary
lineker shouldn't be allowed to say what
he thinks if Alan sugar is allowed to
say what he thinks I mean if you're
going to have guidelines they only work
if they're applied fairly across the
board
one can't escape from the fact that in
this case they look as if they're being
applied on party political lines